shrinking reservoirs depleted aquifers
drying Rivers these images reveal the
scale of the mega drought sweeping the
American West it's the worst drought the
region is seen in at least 1200 years
with more pressure and Water Supplies
one desert City offers a promising
conservation model you fly into Vegas
you see the you know the Bellagio
Fountains and you see the golf courses
and it looks like a land of absolute
waste I've discovered that actually
Southern Nevada is one of the most water
minded places on Earth since 2002
Southern Nevada has cut its Colorado
River water use by 26 percent while also
adding 750 000 people to its population
still severe drought conditions are
forcing the region to find even more
ways to reduce its consumption with the
Colorado River Basin at a dangerous
Tipping Point here's how Las Vegas
offers a road map to making the most out
of every drop of water
in June the federal government ordered
unprecedented water cutbacks asking
western states to reduce their water use
by as much as 30 percent to save the
Colorado River system the Colorado River
really is the lifeblood of the American
southwest it runs for over 1400 miles
and along the way it provides water for
40 million people as one of the
thirstiest cities in the nation's dry
Estate Las Vegas leaders realize they
couldn't afford to gamble on water
on average Nevada receives less than 10
inches of rainfall a year it also gets
the smallest amount of water from the
Colorado River the Colorado River was
divided up about a hundred years ago
under the 1922 Colorado River compact
where you had seven states that were all
negotiating for how much water each
state would be allocated from the river
system at that time with the population
that we had with the lack of potential
for agriculture here in our community it
sort of made sense that perhaps Nevada
did only get a small amount decades
later scientists discovered the compact
severely overestimated how much water
flows down the Colorado River each year
this over allocation of water combined
with warming temperatures and
record-breaking drought has the river
system on the verge of collapse at the
same time the constant pressure on Las
Vegas's water supply has helped
transform the region into a leader in
conservation
[Music]
the Bellagio water fountain on the Las
Vegas Strip is one of the city's most
iconic and noticeable symbols of excess
water use the 8.5 acre man-made lake
holds more than 22 million gallons of
water but nearly all of it is recycled
the thing that most people don't know is
that the Bellagio fountain doesn't use
any of our communities water supply
there was no Colorado River water that
is used for that Fountain it is fed by a
private well that pulls groundwater and
is owned by the hotel still the
recycling system isn't perfect the
fountain could lose millions of gallons
annually to evaporation an MGM Resort
spokesperson said they were committed to
using water responsibly across the
company and supply chain the Las Vegas
Strip obviously is the backbone of our
community but what's really interesting
is that it only uses about five percent
of our communities total water supply
residents who live here use 60 percent
of our communities total water supply so
I don't know any other community that
makes a very small investment of its
water supply to get such great economic
Returns the Bellagio fountain represents
just a fraction of the Region's water
recycling efforts nearly every drop of
water used indoors throughout Southern
Nevada is treated recycled and returned
in near drinkable quality to Lake Mead
according to the Clark County Water
Reclamation District in 2021 this
accounted for about 50 percent of the
Region's total water consumption so the
amount of water that the Las Vegas
Valley recycles is absolutely
unprecedented in the Western United
States Dan Fisher works at the largest
water recycling plant on the Colorado
River basin for every gallon of water
that we return we can take another
gallon of water out without our ability
to recycle our water and safely return
it to the lake and reuse it because we
treat it so effectively without those
things Las Vegas wouldn't be what it is
to keep up with rapid population growth
the Region's water recycling facilities
are nearly always under construction the
wastewater treatment plants cannot get
behind that is just not an option we
have to stay ahead of it we have to keep
building more and more facilities in
order to be able to take that water and
effectively treat it
another way Las Vegas is able to cut
back on its water is by removing one of
its biggest water guzzlers grass when
you consider that grass consumes 73
gallons per square foot to survive in
the Mojave Desert you know that's a
column of water that is 10 feet tall for
every square foot of grass in 1999 the
Southern Nevada Water Authority started
its cash for grass program which
currently pays homeowners three dollars
for each square foot of grass that's
replaced with water efficient Desert
Landscaping the region has removed about
207 million square feet of grass as a
result of this policy no place really in
the American West has been better than
Las Vegas at getting rid of grass it
spread to the rest of the West Phoenix
is doing this Los Angeles now has kind
of a war on grass but Las Vegas really
is the Pioneer more recently a new law
in southern Nevada the first of its kind
in the nation bans non-functional grass
that's the grass and medians and
roadways that is only planted for
decorative purposes ecologists say
grasslands can also be bad for Desert
ecosystems not meant to sustain water
intensive plants
as of today there are approximately 3
000 Acres of non-functional grass
replacing that grass will save about 10
percent of our community's overall water
supply
rigorous conservation efforts don't just
outlaw grass but also dictate when
residents can water their yards or wash
their cars water investigators like this
one Patrol neighborhoods to cite people
who violate rules we leave a courtesy
door hanger with a watering guide
letting them know hey you're not allowed
to water today I think it's important to
note that southern Nevada did not Place
conservation on one sector we did not
just require it of the resorts down on
the Las Vegas Strip we did not just
require it of residence we placed
conservation on the backs of every
single sector in our community
as the drown across the American West
worsens reservoirs across the region are
reaching critical levels this summer the
country's largest Reservoir Lake Mead
fell to a record low you see the
pictures of Lake Mead you see the 200
feet of air where there used to be water
for over the entire Lake unless the
drought subsides we could get to a point
where Lake Mead cannot deliver any water
out of Hoover Dam that's a real
possibility and that's a terrifying
thought the federal government says the
seven Colorado River Basin States still
need to make more water cutbacks and the
fast basically said if you don't do it
voluntarily we reserve the right to make
you we'll we'll decide for you all the
Basin States said they recognized their
shared role in bringing the river system
into balance more recently California
the Region's largest water user promised
to reduce the state's use of Colorado
River Water by 400 000 acre feet every
year for the next three years even as a
leader in water conservation the
Southern Nevada Water Authority says Las
Vegas is finding more ways to cut back
it takes all sectors of your community
in order to contribute to water
conservation and be successful and it's
going to be the same thing on the
Colorado River it is going to take every
water user across every sector to be
contributing to the efforts to reduce
those water demands so that we can bring
this system back into balance